now if we want to get say the equation
of this temperature okay so if we want
to know the temperature as a function of
time okay what kind of information do I
need to know well I'm gonna need to know
that I've got an initial condition but
that won't be enough will it okay I've
got to know how quickly how much this is
stretched out or compressed right how
quickly does it go towards 22 okay so in
situations where you've got like growth
or decay and I radioactive materials
what kind of extra information do they
give you that lets your work out so tell
you yeah they'll give you say for
instance it takes such in such an amount
of time and then after that time is
elapsed you'll have this much of your
quantity so that's what a half-life is
right or in situations which aren't like
radioactive decay they'll say you know
in the year 2000 we have this many
people that was the population and then
10 years later in 2010 the population
was this much okay so in other words you
need to fix points okay so let's say
what would you guess the temperature is
after five minutes
so boiling water 22 degrees is the
ambient temperature what do you think
five minutes
he surprised me drinkable water
drinkable water from boiling right
I mean drinkable orders like I don't
know the hottest you can get on the tap
general is about 55 to 60 I think and
you can sort of is that higher or lower
than you'd expect
hiya I think you can sort of drink that
so I'm gonna call it after five minutes
put up here let's get it to 60 degrees
let's just call it that
okay so what's that going to give us
that means we've got one point for scale
here okay so I know how stretched out or
compressed I am so again watch out for
your scale since I've said 60 and I've
put 50 here so I guess most 60 would be
somewhere up here what that's gonna
correspond suit is point on your graph
which should line up with five five
minutes T equals five okay now all of
this information now is enough to work
out our temperature as a function of
time we're gonna do that but I want to
get some a few other questions as well
I'd like to know the rate of change
that's this DT DT business right I'd
like to do that as a function of the
temperature okay that's what we've been
doing so far this is kind of what we
guessed that but we saw that that broke
down okay so this is evidently not the
way to go okay so if it's not the way to
go what is the way to go and lastly
let's just apply it let's say I don't
know how long will that take
given all of that to get to say 30
degrees how long will it take for it to
drop down to that fun all right let's
have a go at one now this is still
something like an exponential equation
right so T is still gonna have this T
I'm gonna pull up you know I'm just
gonna go back to a it still has this
decay characteristic shape to it but
what difference this is asymptote make
algebraically speaking to our equation
here how would you adjust it
any suggestions if we took off this
asymptote right is 22 and we called that
the actual axis called that the time
axis okay then this would be okay right
so all I've done really it's just taking
this decay shape and I've just shifted
in upwards you see that this is the same
idea you could say I'm just a horizontal
who are they amount to the same thing so
if I want a vertical shift if you've got
a graph right like say Y cos x squared
and you want to put some vertical shift
on it
how do you adjust it you do just add a
constant right for instance x squared
you want to move it up 10 units you just
say plus 10 and do it okay a better more
precise way of saying it is to put the
ten on the other side right because that
connects the shift to the Y value right
so because negative goes up you remember
how it reversed anyway so what am I
gonna do here okay well I'm gonna add on
what I need to get up above right so
that I'm gonna approach tweet to instead
of zero okay so I'm gonna put 22 there
yeah that works
do you see how now this is going to obey
what we actually want for our sort of
limit condition okay as T approaches
infinity what happens to this guy over
here well this is going to become minus
K over really really large number so
this is going to shrink off into
insignificance okay and what you'll be
left with is your 22 all right so this
is going to this is gonna work for us
okay but I still have all of these guys
to worry about how am I gonna work out
these constants what will I use
good in fact my fixed points plural
because I'm going to need both of these
right so usually I mean codes at the
start let's start with the initial
condition so when T equals zero the
actual temperature is a hundred degrees
okay so let's substitute it in that's
inside it's a hundred so far so good
e to the power of zero is just gonna be
one so here I'm gonna be left with hey
okay and then with this 22 it's gonna go
into the other side and I'm left with 78
okay so you can see here by the way why
why I caught myself
this is coefficient here is not T naught
not very helpful : t North because
you're not starting at 78 degrees right
the starting temperature is kind of
made-up all this pot end is pot together
right
there's a okay let's work out K are we
going to use our other fixed point now
right so when T equals five the
temperature is two degrees so I'm gonna
bring it into what I already know which
is 60 that's my left hand side is 22
plus I don't have to write a anymore I
can say what is 78 e to the minus five
okay okay so do a bit of simplifying
this is gonna go over and become 38
right they don't guess I'll divide
through by 78 38 Sony eight they're both
even so I could write that as 19 on
you happy with that
convert it to a log equation so this is
going to be minus 5k the equals log of
that number there and I just want
counter
now could you simplify this could you
put the minus inside or it will change
the 5 whatever yeah you could I think
this is gonna be enough eventually we're
just gonna stick this into our
calculator all right so there's my K
therefore the rent of the point was to
get temperature as a function of time
don't rid of all my other constants
count so I can say the temperature is 22
plus 78 eat it uh this mess okay be
careful with your brackets please there
it is